Ever been used as arm rest by all your friends?
Yeah.
Not fun.
But maybe a little human growth hormone could
help with that.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
I have always said I’m average height, but
growing up I had oddly tall friends.
I wished there was some way to make myself
taller.
I know I’m about average height for a woman,
which is approximately 5’4.
But there are some vertically challenged people
who aren’t so lucky.
Is there something they could do?
Well some people take human growth hormone,
to build lean body mass or to add a few extra
inches to their height.
Human growth hormone is a hormone naturally
produced in high amounts during childhood
and adolescence, but a study published in
The Journal of Clinical Endocrinology & Metabolism
found that secretion decreases with age by
around 14% per decade.
The hormone is produced in the pituitary gland,
located at the base of the brain.
HGH tells the liver to produce a hormone called
insulin-like growth factor-1(IGF-1).
The two hormones work together to tell the
bones, muscles, and other tissues to grow.
But due to various genetic conditions, like
Turner syndrome, SHOX deficiency and Noonan
syndrome, some people just don’t produce
the hormone so they tend to be smaller than
average.
But according to one endocrinologist, if they
take synthetic human growth hormone, they
could gain one to four inches.
HGH does more than add a few inches, it can
even take away fat, according to a study published
in the New England Journal of Medicine.
The study found that HGH deficient adults
who take the synthetic hormone gain lean body
mass and lose some fat body mass, which is
incidentally one of the reasons athletes dope
with it.
But some parents are giving the hormone to
their perfectly healthy, but short children.
Because in our Western culture, we value tallness.
Studies show that taller people are generally
more respected and have higher IQs and according
to several studies published in the Journal
of Applied Psychology and another published
in the Journal of Human Capital, over the
course of a lifetime taller folks tend to
earn more money.
A lot more.
According to lead authors of the Applied Psychology
study, a tall person will “enjoy literally
hundreds of thousands of dollars of earnings
advantage.”
But giving your perfectly healthy but short
kid HGH might not be the best idea.
First of all, it’s pretty expensive; costing
as much as 50,000 dollars.
For spending all that money, it might not
even add height to those without a deficiency.
Plus, it can cause some very serious health
issues.
Too much HGH can cause a condition called
acromegaly, which basically causes hands and
feet swell, overly pronounced facial features,
and excessive sweating.
HGH use can also trigger cardiomyopathy, osteoporosis,
menstrual irregularities, and impotence according
to a study published in the British Journal
of Sports Medicine.
And one study published in the journal Acta
medica Scandinavica found that condition can
increase the risk of premature death from
heart problems.
But still knowing all these risks, people
still take HGH for more superficial reasons.
So if your kid doesn’t have a hormone deficiency
and are thinking of spending upwards of 50,000
dollars to try and boost their height, think
of all the side-effects first.
Being short isn’t really a health condition
and plenty of people wind up just fine looking
up at the world.
Plus they make good arm rests, apparently.
Love science?
Love learning?
What more hand picked stories delivered straight
to your inbox?
Sign up for our newsletter, there’s a link
at the top of the description!
And if you’re wondering more about that
whole being short and living longer thing,
check out this episode right here
So are you short?
Did you get used as arm rest by all your friends?
Yeah story of my life.
Tell me your story down in the comments below.